I fell first, you'll fall next, Heaven's Shop Out, Fallen
Angel, I'm Amelia Fell, Peru.
And I am honored to welcome you all to Doki Doki Rewind
Time, presented by Fantastic Reality.
Before we start the show, I'd like to go over some house
rules.
Photos and videos are a-okay, but please no professional
recording.
If you do take photos, remember to turn off your flash as to
be mindful of our fantastic band here.
If you'd like to share your pictures and memories from
today, feel free to use hashtag Fantastic Reality and
hashtag Doki Rewind Time.
Penlights, UOs, Wotel, Mixes, and Mosh Pits are all okay.
Have fun, but just be mindful of the people all around you.
Merch is available outside those doors back there after the
show and also online for a limited time.
If you'd like to relive today, be sure to buy a VOD ticket.
All right, are you guys ready?
It's the last day of fantastic reality, let me hear you.
Okay, enjoy the show.
Thank you everyone for...
Thank you everyone for coming to the concert!
Are you ready to rewind time?
Of course we gotta start off with a classic.
Come on, dragons.
She was a boy, she was a girl Can I make it any more
obvious?
He was a punk, she did ballet What more can I say?
He wanted her, she'd never tell Secretly she wanted him as
well But all of her friends stuck up their nose And they had
a problem with his baggy clothes He was a skater boy, she
said see you later boy He wasn't good enough She had a
pretty face, but her head was up in place.
She needed to come back down to her turn.
Five years from now, she sits at home, feeding the baby.
She's all alone.
She turns on TV, guess who she sees?
Skater boy rocking out MTV.
She calls up her friends, they already know.
And they've all got tickets to see his show.
She tags along and stands in the crown But look at the man
that she turned down He was a skater boy, she said, see you
later boy He wasn't good enough for her Now he's a superstar
slamming on his guitar Cause her pretty face,
there's more than he needs the
eye He's just a boy, and I'm
just, haven't you heard How we rock each other's world?
I'm with, I'll be backstage after the show
I'll be backstage after the show I'll be at a studio singing
the song you used to know
Do you guys like my new outfit?
That's right, whoa Ha ha, another dokey for the dokeyverse
Thank you everyone for coming to my birthday concert Yeah,
it's my birthday today Are you guys excited?
Can't believe all of America is celebrating me USA, USA,
USA.
Donkey bird, donkey bird, donkey bird.
Oh my God.
Anyway, we have a wonderful show for all you get drives.
Wow, dragoons with a lot of amazing guests.
And I don't think you guys are ready for the set list.
I want to do something very special.
We're traveling back in time when things were a bit simpler
and how we thought the world was going to end in 2012.
So we're all like, huh, YOLO, you know?
And shout out to the live band.
Yes, you heard me.
They're live right now.
I mean, oh yeah, they're on both sides.
Yeah, right here.
And they're real and IEI.
And Chibi Doki's here too.
She's my extra special guest.
And she'll be taking over the concert midway with her own
very special set list.
Anyway, enough yapping from me.
And I hope you guys are very excited.
Are you guys excited?
All right.
dragons it's rewind time I
still hear your voice when you sleep next to me I still feel
your touch in my dream my dream forgive me my weakness but I
don't Without you, it's hard to survive Cause every time we
touch, I get this feeling And every time we kiss, I swear I
could fly Can't you feel my heartbeat fast?
I want this to last, need you by my side Cause every time we
touch, I feel the static And every time we kiss, I reach for
the sky Can't you hear my heartbeat so?
Let you go, what you did in my life.
Your arms are my castle, your heart is my sky.
They wipe away tears that I cry.
That I cry.
The good and the bad times we've been through them.
You make me rise when I fall Cause every time we touch, I
get this feeling And every time we kiss, I swear I could fly
Can't you feel my heartbeat fast?
I want this to last, need you by my side Cause every time we
touch, I feel the static And every time we kiss, I reach for
the sky Can't you hear my heartbeat so hard?
I can't let you go, want you in my life it, tune it, print
it, scan it, send it, fax, rename it, touch it, bring it,
pay it, watch it, turn it, leave it, start formatic, buy it,
use it, break it, fix it, trash it, change it, mail, upgrade
it, charge it, point it, zoom it, press it, snap it, work
it, quick, erase it, write it, cut it, paste it, save it,
load it, check it, quick, rewrite it, plug it, play it, burn
it, rip it, drag and drop it, zip, unzip it, block it, fill
it, call it, find it, view it, code it, jam, unlock it, surf
it, scroll it, pause it, click it, Rate it, tune it, print
it, scan it, send it, fax, rename it, touch it, bring it,
pay it, watch it, turn it, leave it, start formatics.
Technologic.
Buy it, ease it, break it, fix it, trash it, change it,
melt, upgrade it, charge it, build it, zoom it, press it,
snap it, work it, quick erase it, write it, cut it, paste
it, save it, load it, check it, click, rewrite it, plug it,
play it, burn it, flick it, drag and drop it, To fill it,
call it, lock it, search it, scroll it, pause it, click it,
pause it, pause it, switch, update it, name it, rate it,
tune it, hunt it, scan it, send it, ask your name it, touch
it, ring it, pay it, watch it, check, buy it, use it, break
it, use it, trash it, change it, melt, upgrade it, charge
it, coin it, zoom it, mess it, snap it, work it, quick erase
it, write it, cut it, paste it, save it, load it, check it,
quickly write it, plug it, play it, burn it, rip it, drive
it, drop it, set, unzip it, punch it, ring it,
Burn it, rip it, dry it, drop it, zip it, unzip it, beam it,
rate it, turn it, print it, scan it, send it, fax, rename
it, launch it, ring it, pay it, watch it, turn it, leave it,
start, format it, buy it, ease it, break it, fix it, trash
it, change it, mail, upgrade it, charge it, bonus, unit,
fast it, snapped it, work it, quickly, raise it, write it,
cut it, paste it, save it, load it, check it, quickly write
it, flush it, play it,
fix it, trash it, change it, mail, upgrade it, charge it,
bonus, human, fast it, snapped it, Play it, paste it, save
it, load it, check it, quick rewrite it, barge it, play it,
burn it, rip it, drag and drop it, set, unzip it, surf it,
scroll it, volume it, rate it, tune it, print it, scan it,
send it, fax, remade it, buy it, ease it, break it, fix it,
trash it, change it, now upgrade it, charge it, coin it,
zoom it, mess it, snap it, work it, quick, erase it, write
it, cut it, paste it, save it, load it, check it, quick
rewrite it, barge it, play it,
block it, surf it, scroll it, pause it, click,
technologic, technologic, Technologic.
Technologic.
Purdue is watching at home.
Yes, I'm talking to you guys right there.
this is now the end of the free stream preview so if you
want to keep watching maybe check out the streaming tickets
sorry this way check out the streaming tickets pin in the
chat right here sorry I don't know my left and right you
guys know this already you can also use the chat to hang out
with all the other dragons watching too now for the dragons
here at the venue standing here I didn't forget about you
guys, by the way.
You can also get the streaming ticket so you can re-watch it
and relive the experience over and over and over and over
and over and over again.
So yeah, also one more important, very, very important
announcement.
This is the most important announcement of your life.
Don't forget to buy my merch.
We have exclusive concert merch that you can order right now
as a little memorabilia who said skip ad there is no skip ad
this is an integrated product placement you're stuck here
with me it's like in the movies you know we're some guys
like crying about his fucking dead wife and his friend goes
hey this cook will cheer you up anyway back to the show